you said you said something that got me
thinking so in your eyes
if you said world war 4
for russia is going to be against china
meaning world war iii is going to be us
right
so if let's just say russia does choose
to attack
ukraine
u.s gets involved and russia says screw
this i'm sick and tired of the way us by
administration is handling it i'm
attacking us as well done but i'm going
to take a different angle
if he does and let's just say he
succeeds let's go to the succeeding part
he succeeds and it's a debacle here you
know you use the word it's a mess over
here in the u.s
then
whether he likes it or not he has to
face off the last bully that's going to
be stronger than him because he's
getting stronger every year which is
china so it would be a very bad move on
his end
to do anything to us because he's gonna
need u.s long term to protect them in
case something happens with china
because china is the guy that's standing
alone by themselves buying up all these
small different places they're
buying the cobalt in uh you know uh
africa they're you know their their
strategy with iran with oil the way
they're taking it is a very different
strategy on how china's taking it
would you say the same thing would you
agree with that that russia needs
america to make sure long-term they're
protected from china
the russians are chess players and i
think that that analysis
is possibly the way the russians are
thinking about this and it's even
possible that
that one of the reasons they have we
haven't been attacked yet is precisely
because
of that that they that they need us in
the long run looking toward world war iv
but i wouldn't count on on on
on
that forbearance
forever okay you know uh there's gonna
come a point where our involvement in
ukraine if we decide to go the other way
and become more deeply involved uh you
know uh uh kill more russian generals
kill more russians on the ground try to
force try to defeat putin in ukraine
there's going to come another place
where he says well i've got to be
concerned with my immediate survival you
know and uh and and there's no hope of
negotiating with uh with the west but
let me say this and conclude uh
another thought on this about the
negotiating the peace with putin uh
through ukraine
what if russia decides not to negotiate
with us
okay that's the other thing
i mean one of the hardest things in
managing foreign policy and defense
policies is is situational awareness
what is our situation via v russia you
know is it possible to to play ball with
them uh the way we did with stalin in
world war ii
and if and
and
it will tell us so much if we try to
negotiate with putin on the basis of his
own peace treaty and then he says no
deal i don't
uh you know uh this treat that i'm not
even going to negotiate you with that
treaty because i'm in ukraine now that's
going to tell us
a lot about what this war in ukraine is
really about for putin it will tell us i
believe that uh uh that putin is uh is
stalin and zee is uh is uh hitler in
1939 and ukraine is poland z meaning
yeah the the dictator of china yeah and
and and and and ukraine is poland all
over again and that this is all part of
a plot by these guys okay that they're
and that unified behind
worried about losing in ukraine and uh
and that this is the big move okay that
this is the big move this is 1939 all
over again
it's important for us to know that
that's a very good point you just made
so are they maybe waiting
for
you know for us to make the move for
them to say we didn't you know we
reacted to your
behavior you did this and then we had to
go and protect ourselves because you got
involved in something we told you stay
at it so are they almost waiting
for us to be aggressive
uh
that that could be the case they could
be wanting the us to come into ukraine
uh you know as i said before the
austerlit scenario right provocative
right
intervene a lot of the things the
atrocities for example almost seem
calculated to inflame western opinion so
that we'll just on impulse
send our forces in there so that they'll
be destroyed i would also point out to
by the way i mean it really isn't
pointed out uh you know when you look at
the balance of power uh here you know
russia is fighting the ukraine war with
one hand behind its back you know i mean
they've only got 200 000 troops in
ukraine they've got a 2 million man army
they've got 20 000 tanks they only have
you know four four thousand tanks or so
the air force has hardly played that
significant role the air force's has
really held back uh it's really it's
it's either incredibly gross
incompetence which is what we're being
told or something else is going on here
in terms of holding back all this power
and uh uh i think it's time for us to be
less dysfunctionally optimistic and a
little more paranoid before we get uh go
forward and think about
if we're wrong again here the way we
were in afghanistan and the way we were
in vietnam what's the worst that could
happen and the worst could happen is the
destruction of the west if we play this
thing all right so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]